here's the secret I've literally been
watching Vanderpump rules all day my
water always stay hydrated when you're
watching filthy trashy television
welcome to tipsy Thursday where I give
you tips on life is clearly I'm an
expert I what am I telling her to ask
you guys what did you want to learn how
to do today someones adjusting that'd be
my bf which I assume is boyfriend and
not bread freak unless you're into that
in which case that's the least of your
worries oh my god I've been hanging out
with Hannah officially too long it's
always very um scary when you want to
ask the one to be your boyfriend so I'll
do for you no shame in my game
just basketballs cuz we playin
basketball so the guy that you want to
be your boyfriend just send in this
video and Thomas start right now hi
pretty do you think that you'd want to
be a person that like we put each
other's tongues in each other's mouths
willingly and then we also share
cheesecake wanna be like that person
that goes to like a series of chain
restaurants with me on different
occasions and then eventually we touch
the concave and convex areas of our body
together and our mutually pleasing
fashion we like be that guy that buys me
stuff on special occasions and then gets
frustrated because I don't want to have
sex with you when I'm on my period I
want to like create a special bottom
together it's based on like physical and
mental attraction and then like
sometimes go on trips but we realize
that we're not good at planning and so
we constantly keep getting the airfare
days wrong would you like be that dude
that opens up and shares the steepest
insecurities with me as a way to create
more meaningful spiritual connections
and then sometimes I'll let you put your
D in my hem want to spend some time
together planning a future together and
then one time I might let you try the
but but like never again because I'll
quickly realize I like you but like
there are other ways to show it would
you be the man
say like forget my birthday and it
really bothers me because I love you
dude
but then you leave and you go buy me my
favorite flowers and I'm like oh that
softens me a little bit but I still
always remember and then when you're
like are you okay I'm like I'm fine and
then you're like no really and I'm like
no really I'm fine because you know you
understand that I sometimes have a hard
time communicating my feelings but
nevertheless like cool birthday what I
like be that person that I talk to you
about my deepest fears and we can
comfort each other over the relatable
human nature of it all but also at the
same time be incredibly afraid to take
[ __ ] around each other on account of the
insecure thought of you imagining
something coming out of my butt hole
that started by going in my mouth well
you'd be the guy that makes you want to
shave my legs in the winter they go home
to help
[ __ ] work I don't know will you be the
person in my life that equally makes me
happy and terrified and ultimately just
a better version of myself unless I find
out that you're actually like the
witness protection program because you
murdered a dude and cold her blood and
I'm like gosh dang not the person I
thought you were and then I go to
therapy for years and continue to live
the rest of my life with a deep-seated
fear of men and ultimately an underlying
trust issue with the men in general that
I thought I'd fixed from my dad but you
stirred up the pot again so